the instrument is not at all like a
church organ first of all being an
orchestral organ or a theater organ it
comes at the production of tone from a
symphonic point-of-view and the theatre
organs in the nineteen teens and 20s
were voiced as much like an orchestra as
was possible through wind blown pipes
well now through this Allen organ this
is sample technology of those same pipes
and so we're hearing an electronic
reproduction of a pipe reproduction of
the Symphony Orchestra be that as it may
we go through all of the different
families of tones so you could be the
one-man band and you had fanfare reads
like an English Post horn or a tuba
which had the biggest of the notes base
and that would have been a pipe 16 feet
tall to produce that we have church
organ sounds
or big church organ sounds
then big fat flutes stop on only theater
organs called a tibia and it was used
two ways first you could imitate the
circus Callie Oh
or then if you used it the way we will
in the in the picture when the lovers
are kissing on screen it's this
and then there's the clarinet very much
like the orchestral clarinet
and then we've got the the oboe that you
would find in the orchestra
and the bowed strings
in the orchestral flute and a funny
little thing for you Latin scholars
called a Vox Humana of course that meant
human voice and too imaginative heroes
that was supposed to sound like a choir
or a choir of angels humming
to some other imaginative hearers it
sounded like frogs and the swamp and
that was part and parcel of what people
did with these instruments as well as
doing all sorts of imitations but there
were a real instruments in the chambers
a glockenspiel or xylophone or you had
the chimes or the chills and the tap
symbol as well so these were some of the
things then that created the sounds of
the unit orchestra as they called it in
the day because it was a unit that one
musician could play and I could go on
and on and on and you could imitate
storms and airplanes and cats meowing
and dogs barking you name it you could
do it on these steam engines starting up
a band full of bagpipes etc etc so this
is the genuine original synthesizer was
what it was in the 1920s women when it
was a pipe organ and so here we are
synthesizing the synthesizer
you